so one of the things that you just did  talk about was the notch count why do  you think that the virginity age impacts  that a woman that's been with 100 guys  50 guys 25 guys is much much less likely  to be able to form a pair bond with a  guy than a woman that's a virgin or has  only been with one or two guys and a  woman that lost her virginity at 13 or  14 is less likely to be a good long-term  partner than a woman that lost her  virginity at 23. I was raised Mormon so  super religious and like sex wasn't even  in the question until much later but now  I'm like damn maybe that was really  beneficial for me because there was a  value put on virginity there was a value  put on  the girls especially like saving things  for marriage well there's a reason why  the prize when Arabs go to you know the  afterlife whatever is 70 virgins and not  a Mercedes or a Ferrari right